Transcriber: Abdullah Morgan
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
صورة عن ألف كلمة.
أحب أن أفتح خطابي اليوم بسؤال،
أحب أن أسأله لكم جميعًا،
ما هو التعبير بالنسبة لكم؟
لأن مفهوم التعبير يختلف من شخص إلى شخص.
فعندما تأتي وتبحث
عن مفهوم التعبير من المعجم،
سيقول لك أن التعبير هو مصدر عبر
أو إظهار الأفكار والعواطف بالكلام،
أو الحركات أو قسمات الوجه.
لكن المعجم لم يذكر التعبير من خلال الفن .
التعبير من خلال الفن
-يا جماعة الخير- شئ مهم جداً،
ولا أجد كثيرًا من الناس
تتكلم عنه في مجتمعنا اليوم.
ساعدني التعبير من خلال الفن أن أحوّل
حياتي الاجتماعية والعقلية 180 درجة.
مسّاكم الله بالخير يا جماعة،
معكم أوس بورحمة،
أنا طالب في مدرسة البيان ثانية اللغة،
ومع أنني طالب، فأنا أيضًا مصور وصانع أفلام
حيث لي مدة ثماني سنين في هذا المجال.
واستطعتُ من خلال التصوير أن أشتغل
مع شركات كويتية وخليجية،
واليوم -حمدًا لله- بدأنا في العالمية.
بفضل الله، منذ سنتين خططت لمشروعي
وشركتي اليوم وهي، “فوتوجرافي باي أوس”
“فوتوجرافي باي أوس” جعلتني أتعامل
واشترك مع هذه الشركات.
لكني اليوم لست موجود ًا
لأتكلم عن إنجازاتي كمصور،
بقدر ما سأتكلم عن سبب استمراري
لمدة ثماني سنين بهذا المجال،
و لماذا أنصحكم كلكم أن تكتشفوا
الفن وتستطيعوا التعبير به.
الكتمان؛
الكتمان موضوع كبير جدًا
خصوصًا في مجتمعنا العربي،
ألا وهو أنك تحكر وتحبس مشاعرك وأفكارك
وأحاسيسك ولا تعبر عنها للجميع.
التعبير عن طريق الفن يعطيك فرصة أن تعبر
عن مشاعرك وأن تؤخر موضوع الكتمان.
وهذا هو إجابة لماذا استمررت ثماني سنين.
الكتمان جعلني أحبس أفكاري
ومشاعري ولا أعبر عنها للكل.
جاءتني فترة -لو يتذكروننى بعض الناس
القريبة مني- لم أكن اتكلم كثيرًا،
حتى في بعض الأحيان ترى فجأة
دمعة تنزل من عيني.
من هنا اتجهت للتعبير من خلال الفن،
والحمد لله اكتشفت التصوير،
ومن خلال التصوير استطعت حل مشكلة الكتمان.
و الحمد لله، الذين يعرفوننى شخصيًا اليوم،
يعلمون أن حياتي الاجتماعية
تطورت 180 درجة بسبب التصوير.
هذا -الله يسلمكم- أوس
الذي رأيتموه قبل برهة،
هذا كان أوس الذي مرّ بمشكلة الكتمان،
والحمد لله في سنينه الآتية استطاع
أن يحل مشكلة الكتمان من خلال الفن.
وسأريكم بعض الأمثلة عن كيف استطعت
أن أحول الطاقة السلبية أو الطاقة الإيجابية
إلى صورة فنية أو لوحة فنية
تُعلّق في بيوتكم.
ترون عن يميني هذه الصورة،
قصتها حلوة جدًا، وقصتها بسيطة،
وغريبة نوعًا ما.
اصطنعت هذه الصورة بسبب الإلهام.
هناك تطبيق اشتهر منذ فترة
واسمه “كلوب هاوس”،
كان فيه ما يشبه غرفة دردشة،
تتكلم عن دعاية معينة أخرجها مخرج معين.
أكثر ما ألهمني هو طريقة
تقبّل نقد الناس وانتقاداتهم،
لهذا المخرج.
تخيل أنه كان أكثر من مائتي شخص ينتقدُ
ويعيب ويكتب كلامًا سيئًا جدًا عن الإخراج،
وعلى الدعاية نفسها.
ولكن الطريقة التي تقبّل بها النقد ذاك
المخرج -وهو عبد العزيز الجسمي-
كان ملهمًا جدًا جدًا.
و ألهمني بأن أريد أن أصبح مثل هذا المخرج.
أريد أن أتعلم منه، وأرغب في يومٍ
من الأيام أن أصل إلى نفس درجة هذا المخرج.
اشتهر المخرج بإنتاج دعايات
ومقاطع فيديو غريبة جدًا،
التي لا يفكر فيها أي أحد.
لو ترون، قد أحضرت فنجانًا أو دلة عريبة،
وبدلًا من استخدام فنجان،
استخدمت كوبًا إنجليزيًا قديمًا.
فاستطعت أن أدمج بين الثقافتين:
الثقافة الكويتية والثقافة الإنجليزية،
وأخرج هذه الصورة التي ترونها أمامكم.
الصورة على اليمين التي هي شوربة عدس،
قصتها بسيطة جدًا وربما حدثث معكم
جميعًا على الأغلب.
كنت ألعب لعبة “بادل”
التي اشتهرت هذه الأيام،
ولعبت مع شخص لم أكن على علاقة جيدة معه،
وأثناء ما كنا نلعب، كان يستفز دماغي ويقول
بأني لا أستطيع اللعب وكلام من هذا القبيل.
وفجاة قال لي، هل أنت مصور طعام؟
تخيل أن تصبح مصور طعام!
الناس تتخصص، وتقوم بفعل هذا وذاك،
وانت تتخصص في مجال تصوير الطعام!
لا أدري لماذا أخذت كلامه بشكل شخصي.
رجعت إلى البيت، وبسرعة جمعت أي عدّة عندي
وسترون انها ستكون أبسط شيء صورته،
وهي شوربة العدس،
و استطعت أن أنتج هذه الصورة.
شاركتُ هذه الصورة في مسابقة عالمية
وهي مسابقة “بِنك ليدي فود فوتو أورد”
و هي أكبر مسابقة لتصوير الطعام في العالم،
و شارك بها أكثر من ثمانية آلاف شخص،
والحمد لله، وبفضل الله استطعت
أن أصل إلى النهائي في هذه المسابقة،
بسبب أنني حولت الطاقة السلبية
التي أخذتها من هذا الشخص،
إلى هذه اللوحة التي ترونها أمامكم.
[صوري عن ألف كلمة]
وهذا هو الشيء -يا جماعة الخير-
صوري أنا عن ألف كلمة.
و قبل أنهي خطاب اليوم، أريد أن أوجه لكم
جميعًا رسالة ألا وهي كلمة واحدة: اكتشفها،
مثلما أنا اكتشفت الفن
واكتشفت التصوير بالعمر الصغير،
أتمنى أنكم كلكم تكتشفون الفن أو الطريقة
التي يمكنكم التعبير بها  غير الكلام،
غير الحركات و غير قسمات الوجه.
لأنه في المستقبل، من الممكن الشخص
الذي ترتاح إليه وتعبر له و تقول له كل شئ،
وكل حكاياتك لا يكون موجودًا!
أو من الممكن في المستقبل لا تجد تعبيرًا،
يعبّر عن المشكلة أو الموضوع الذي تواجهه.ا
يعني أنا لو فعلت هكذا، سترون أنني مصدوم،
لكن يمكن أن توجد فكرة
أكبر بكثير من تلك الصدمة،
والتي لا تستطيع التعبير عنها
بالكلام أو بتعابير الوجه أو بالحركات.
يعطيكم العافية، سامحوني على التقصير .
نراكم على خير إن شاء الله .
(تصفيق)